okay some questions from Reddit
ask him ask Levy if he deep down hates
his audience I saw that yeah I saw I saw
that was someone I have a I have a
love-hate relationship with the chess
subreddit yeah so that's why some of
those questions were going to be tough
I have a love-hate relationship do you
think that's a tough question or is that
come from a place of Love ah very very
tough to say very tough to say uh love
and hate like they're basically next
door neighbors on Reddit I feel like
correct they oscillate very quickly
between each other yes so Reddit chess
specifically I think is
mostly folks who are around before the
chess boom
so the chest is the chest subreddit
sorry yeah yeah so a lot of them have
been around for five years seven years
ten years even more and I think the
average age on Reddit is lower than the
average age on these chess subreddit I
think that the chess subreddit is beyond
the age of 20 maybe even 25 like a lot
of folks they're Ancient Ancient people
they're amazing 20s yeah I mean not 15
or 16. uh Anarchy chest is younger so
Anarchy chess is basically chess memes
this is great A lot of stupid memes on
there do they like you or no or is it
they did until my crypto sponsorship
um which is a separate convo that I'm
more than happy to have uh but uh yeah
so my relationship with the Reddit chess
subreddit is tough because my content on
YouTube
stops at a certain point with them they
can't learn from me because I'm
tailoring to 95 of my audience which is
about 16 1700 and below and I have a lot
of content where I
jokingly make fun of low rated players
and everyone's in on it and we all have
fun and I laugh at myself a ton the life
as you can even see in this conversation
I but just like you mentioned in with
with clips and out of context things
folks have already formed the perception
of my personality
there's nothing I can do to win them
back and I think the dominant percentage
of the loudest group of folks on the
chess subreddit they just they have a
certain perception of me it's not going
to change
and you add something like
cryptocurrency sponsorship which
people on Reddit just in general are
relatively negative on the subject
is going to start you know snowballing
more and more so if you ever look up a
thread of should I buy a Gotham course
and it's on Reddit chess it's gonna say
no everyone's calling it a scam
overpriced
interesting I got I I heard a lot of
really positive stuff I don't know where
I was on Reddit in general about me yeah
you might have you might have been
looking for it you might have not been
looking for for negative things and I
know I was looking for like best
Educators online like that kind of stuff
I don't I'll it might have not been read
to chest I'll be totally honest with you
if you ever go there and look for
something like best Recaps or best
educational content for intermediates
I'm not mentioned I might not be
mentioned because I'm already expected
to be on the list so they just kind of
want to generally shout out smaller
creators totally fine with that and I'm
not even going on this whole explanation
because I want to win folks back it's
just sort of the reality of the
situation a lot of my stuff is really
clickbaity and I'm playing the YouTube
game yeah they don't want that